Вітаю, друзі!
Мене звати Марія Растворова.
Я вчитель географії
“Новопечерської школи”.
На уроці сьогодні ми з вами дізнаємося
про динаміку чисельності населення світу.
Поцікавимося факторами, які
впливають на чисельність населення світу.
Дізнаємося, що таке
статево-вікова структура населення
та як можна прочитати
статево-вікову піраміду.
Дізнаємося, що означає
поняття “демографічна політика”,
“демографічний вибух”,
”демографічне старіння” тощо.
І, звичайно, дізнаємося багато цікавого.
На початку нашого уроку
пропоную пригадати наступне.
Перше питання:
що таке природний приріст та що
означає – відтворення населення?
Всім нам з вами відомо, що на чисельність
населення впливають два основні фактори –
це природний приріст
та механічний приріст.
Механічний приріст населення
відбувається внаслідок міграцій
з одного регіону чи країни в іншу країну.
В той час як природний приріст населення
залежить від двох показників –
народжуваності та смертності.
І відповідно
якщо показник народжуваності
переважає над показником смертності,
то відбувається зростання
чисельності населення.
Якщо ж навпаки, то кількість
населення знижується.
На початку нашого уроку
хочу навести деякі цифри.
В 1820 році населення нашої
планети досягло 1 мільярду осіб.
Втім це був далеко не рекорд.
Вже у 1927 році на планеті
проживало два мільярди осіб.
А в 2011 році кількість населення
на Землі вже складала 7 мільярдів.
Демографи – це вчені,
які досліджують чисельність населення та
роблять демографічні
прогнози, передбачають,
що найближчим часом на планеті Земля
буде проживати 8 мільярдів людей.
Подивимося на графік динаміки
чисельності населення світу.
Бачимо пунктирну лінію, що
відображає наскільки стрімко
за останні 300 років зросла
кількість населення в світі.
Втім, якщо детально проаналізувати
регіональні відмінності, то можемо побачити,
що найбільш стрімко
чисельність населення зростала
і зростає в країнах
Азії та країнах Африки,
в той час як чисельність
населення в країнах Європи і країнах
Океанії характеризується менш
швидкими темпами приросту.
Спробуємо пояснити, чому так відбувається.
Швидкий темп зростання
чисельності населення в світі
і його стабільність називається
демографічним вибухом.
І демографічний вибух є
характерним для країн Азії та Африки.
В той же час далеко не всі країни в світі
характеризуються такою
тенденцією, як демографічний вибух.
Навпаки в країнах, що колись належали
до пострадянського табору,
відбувається демографічна
криза або – депопуляція,
що характеризується
скороченням чисельності населення.
Зокрема на цьому слайді ми бачимо графік,
який відображає динаміку чисельності
населення в такій країні як Болгарія.
І тут ми спостерігаємо такий
дуже-дуже швидкий темп
падіння чисельності населення
починаючи з 90-х років
аж до 2015 року.
Приблизно така картина характерна
і для інших пострадянських
країн, і для України зокрема.
Для розвинутих країн світу характерний
такий демографічний тренд
як “демографічне старіння”.
Демографічне старіння – це зростання
частки літніх людей у
загальній чисельності населення.
Тепер розглянемо типи
відтворення населення.
Для того, щоб краще зрозуміти це питання,
уявімо традиційну родину, яка
складається з чоловіка і жінки.
І вони можуть мати різну кількість дітей.
В разі, якщо чоловік і жінка народжують
і виховують одну дитину, відповідно –
в перспективі кількість
населення буде зменшуватися.
Таким чином – це звужений
тип відтворення населення.
Якщо чоловік і жінка
народжують двоє дітей,
то відповідно – в перспективі кількість
населення залишається сталою.
І в разі, якщо чоловік і жінка
народжують троє і більше дітей,
це буде розширений тип відтворення
населення, який в перспективі призведе
до збільшення чисельності
населення в цьому регіоні чи країні.
Звужений тип відтворення
населення зазвичай
формує перший тип відтворення
населення, для якого характерний
низький рівень народжуваності
але висока тривалість життя.
Перший тип відтворення населення
переважає в розвинутих країнах світу.
Це пов’язано із культурними нормами,
коли зазвичай європейці чи американці
довгий час присвячують своєму саморозвитку
та навчанню, побудові кар’єри.
Потім, в більш пізньому віці,
ніж, наприклад, вихідці з азіатських
чи африканських країн, укладають
шлюб і, відповідно, пізніше народжують.
Втім, завдяки високому
розвитку медицини в цих
країнах та гарним
соціально-економічним умовам,
ці люди можуть прожити довше.
Розширений тип відтворення населення
корелює із другим типом
відтворення населення,
який передбачає високі
темпи народжуваності,
але, в той же час –
коротку тривалість життя.
Другий тип відтворення населення переважає
у тих країнах, що розвиваються,
де недостатньо розвинута медицина,
низький соціально-економічний рівень,
не дуже сприятливі умови життя населення.
Втім, з часом тип
відтворення може змінюватися.
І відповідно цей факт,
що тип відтворення в
певній країні чи регіоні
може змінюватися,
наштовхнув американського
демографа Ф. Ноутстайна на
думку про те, що є різні стадії
демографічного переходу.
Розглянемо їх більш детально.
Для першої фази демографічного
переходу притаманні
дуже високі показники
народжуваності й смертності.
Відповідно дуже низький природний приріст.
І нині ця стадія вже майже завершена.
На другій стадії демографічного переходу
відбувається різке скорочення смертності,
насамперед – завдяки розвитку медичної
галузі та за збереження традиційно
високого рівня народжуваності, що і
є причиною демографічного вибуху.
На третій стадії відбувається
збереження низьких показників смертності,
інколи – навіть їх певне зростання
через старіння населення.
Народжуваність також знижується,
проте дещо перевищує смертність
і це забезпечує зростання
чисельності населення.
І на четвертій стадії
демографічного переходу
показники народжуваності
і смертності збігаються,
що означає перехід до стабілізації
демографічних показників
і коливань населення.
Нині процес демографічного переходу
завершили розвинуті країни світу
зокрема – європейські країни та
країни Американського континенту.
В процесі різкого падіння
народжуваності перебувають такі країни як
Мексика, Бразилія, Аргентина,
Туреччина, Україна та інші.
Безперечно, на рівень
народжуваності та смертності, а, отже, на
природний приріст населення,
впливає цілий комплекс факторів.
І зараз ми спробуємо
розглянути з вами деякі з них.
Серед чинників природного руху населення,
зокрема виділяють природні фактори.
Наприклад, в певній тропічній державі, на
жаль, може статися голод через посуху і,
таким чином, через недостатність
їжі частина населення може померти.
До соціально-економічних чинників, що
впливають на природний рух населення,
можна навести зокрема
приклад того, що в певній країні
є достатньо гарна
інфраструктура для батьків і дітей.
Наприклад,
як матерям, так і татам
надається декретна відпустка.
Високий соціально-економічний
рівень життя населення,
звичайно що, стимулює
вищий рівень народжуваності.
В той же час, високий
розвиток медицини забезпечує
літніх людей доступом до
медичного обслуговування і
відповідно подовжує їх тривалість життя.
Також до чинників природного
руху населення можна
віднести демографічні,
політичні, культурні.
Наприклад, в розвинутих країнах, таких як
європейські країни чи
країни Північної Америки,
у зв’язку з сучасними трендами
поширений рух childfree,
коли люди з певних причин
відмовляються мати дітей.
Також до чинників природного руху
населення належать психологічні чинники.
Прикладом впливу
психологічних чинників на
природний приріст населення
була зокрема ситуація,
яка склалася після II Світової війни в
країнах Європи та Північної Америки.
Люди, які були стомлені від II Світової
війни і відкладали народження дітей,
кохання, щастя до кращих часів,
вмить вирішили все це наздогнати.
І тому, саме після II Світової
війни, в Європі, США та
країнах Радянського Союзу
спостерігався сплеск народжуваності.
Також на природний рух населення
впливають військові чинники,
наприклад, в ході військових
дій може відбуватися
загибель людей – як військових,
так і мирного населення.
Також військові дії впливають на
природний приріст і в перспективі.
В зв’язку з тим, що протягом
війни вбивають і чоловіків, і жінок,
то в подальшому це може
призводити до таких незаповнених місць
в статево-віковій піраміді (до
чого ми дійдемо трохи пізніше).
Також до чинників
природного руху населення
належать юридичні
фактори і етнічні фактори.
Наприклад, ми з вами знаємо,
що представники певних етносів
традиційно воліють мати
велику кількість дітей.
Як ми з вами знаємо,
демографія – це наука
про чисельність
населення та його динаміку.
Одним з інструментів демографії і
одним із найбільш розповсюджених способів
передачі інформації про
структуру та чисельність населення,
про його статевий і
віковий склад є такий графік,
який називається статево-вікова піраміда.
Коли ми розглядаємо конфігурацію,
тобто форму статево-вікової піраміди,
ми можемо легко зрозуміти: яка
вікова група переважає в структурі
населення даної держави та яка
стать переважає – чоловіки чи жінки.
Поясню як це працює.
Кожна стрічка в статево віковій
піраміді відображає проміжок 5 років.
Відповідно ми можемо
прослідкувати, скільки в
суспільстві нараховується
дітей від 0 до 5 років;
відповідно скільки, наприклад,
нараховується людей від 25 до 30 років;
скільки людей, наприклад,
від 75 до 80 років і так далі.
І також у статево-віковій
піраміді можна побачити
співвідношення між кількістю
жінок і чоловіків різного віку.
На даному слайді ми бачимо
дві статево-вікові піраміди.
Статево-вікова піраміда, яка позначена як
“а”, належить такій державі як Афганістан.
А піраміда ”б” належить такій
європейській державі як Австрія.
Для Афганістану, як тієї
країни що розвивається,
характерний другий тип відтворення,
що характеризується високими
темпами народжуваності.
Відповідно буде значна частка
дітей і людей молодого віку.
Втім, у зв’язку з недостатнім
розвитком та фінансуванням медицини,
в зв’язку з військовими загрозами,
незначна
частка населення досягає похилого віку,
що призводить до такої
конфігурації статево-вікової
піраміди як трикутник, що
стрімко звужується догори.
Якщо ж ми розглянемо статево-вікову
піраміду такої країни як Австрія,
що, нагадаю, належить до
розвинутих країн світу, то побачимо,
що нам ця піраміда нагадує
якийсь тропічний фрукт
з піком у середині її висоти.
Це відповідає першому типу відтворення
населення, який характерний для Австрії –
незначна кількість дітей і людей
молодого віку в структурі населення;
втім, значна частка
людей середнього віку і
достатньо велика частка
людей старшого віку.
Така конфігурація статево-вікової
піраміди Австрії відображає ті чинники,
які впливають на природний
приріст в цій державі –
це високі соціально-економічні стандарти
життя та високий рівень розвитку медицини.
Отже запам’ятали –
основним графіком, який
відображає статево-вікову
структуру населення є що?
Правильно – статево-вікова піраміда.
І також ми щойно з вами сказали про те,
що статево-вікова піраміда
відображає частку населення різного віку.
Втім, також, уважно роздивившись
конфігурацію статево-вікової піраміди,
можна побачити, що в
різних країнах світу в більш
старшому віці переважають
або жінки, або чоловіки.
Природно склалося так,
що завжди народжується
більше хлопчиків, аніж дівчаток.
Наприклад, зазвичай на 104
хлопчика народжується 84 дівчинки.
Втім, через певні природні
процеси та суспільні фактори,
з часом співвідношення
дівчат і хлопців вирівнюється.
А згодом, вже в старшому віці, кількість
жінок перевищує кількість чоловіків.
Але давайте дізнаємось,
кого все-таки більше в світі –
чоловіків чи жінок і в яких саме країнах?
Отже в яких країнах світу та чому
переважають жінки, а де чоловіки?
Кількісне переважання чоловіків над
жінками спостерігається в таких країнах:
по-перше – це країни, де становище
жінок є несприятливим або незахищеним,
наприклад – це держави, де дозволені
ранні шлюби, щодня майже 47 000 дівчат
по всьому світу виходять
заміж у віці раніше, ніж 18 років,
а також це можуть бути
численні і ранні пологи,
які можуть призвести до загибелі матері.
Також кількісне переважання
чоловіків над жінками спостерігається
в країнах, де відбувається
великий приплив чоловічої сили.
А також найбільше переважання чоловіків
над жінками зареєстровано в Індії.
Там кількість чоловіків переважає
кількість жінок аж на 44 мільйони.
В Китаї кількість чоловіків переважає
кількість жінок на 34,5 мільйони.
Чому це так саме в Китаї, ми
з вами з’ясуємо трохи пізніше.
Важливо зазначити, що
статевий склад населення
формується під впливом
демографічних факторів
це, нагадаю, народжуваність,
смертність та міграції,
а також під впливом
соціально-політичних процесів.
Це зокрема війни та значні
втрати чоловічого населення.
Відповідно до статистики Фонду
народонаселення ООН за 2016 рік,
чисельність чоловіків перевищує
кількість жінок майже на 35 мільйонів:
в 101 державі світу – більше жінок,
а у 84-х країнах світу – більше чоловіків,
в 24-х країнах – ця кількість
приблизно однакова.
І, як і інші демографічні показники,
співвідношення чоловіків та жінок
не однакове в тих країнах, що
розвиваються і в розвинутих країнах.
Отже щойно ми з вами з’ясували:
що в різних країнах світу проживає різна
кількість жінок і різна кількість чоловіків
і таке різне співвідношення зумовлене
багатьма соціально-економічними,
політичними, демографічними
та іншими факторами.
А тепер давайте дізнаємося більше про ті
країни, де в світі
проживає найбільше людей.
Для цього ми з вами звернемося до карти.
Нагадую, що відомий
грецький історик Геродот
колись сказав: “Карта
– це мова географії”.
Перед нами карта “Чисельність
населення країн світу”.
Бачимо тут шкалу, яка за допомогою
інтенсивності кольору відображає –
скільки населення проживає
в різних країнах світу.
Так, зокрема, найбільш темним
кольором позначені тут держави,
де проживає більш ніж мільярд
людей; темно-синім кольором
позначені держави, де проживає
більше ніж 100 мільйонів людей;
таким от ультрамариновим
кольором позначені
держави, де проживає
більш ніж 50 мільйонів людей;
і ось, наприклад, таким
світло-жовтим (лимонним) кольором
показано держави, де проживає
більше ніж 1 мільйон людей.
Якщо ми звернемо увагу на цю карту і
детально придивимось до відтінків кольору,
то побачимо, що країнами з найвищою
чисельністю населення є Китай та Індія.
До речі, саме ці країни – Індія та Китай
є лідерами за приростом населення.
До країн світу, де проживає
найменша кількість людей належать,
як ми бачимо, Монголія,
країни Прибалтики і Білорусь,
країни Скандинавського півострова та
деякі країни Африки і Південної Америки.
Зазначу, що чисельність
населення країн світу також залежить
від цілого ряду різноманітних факторів,
включаючи соціо-економічні чинники,
включаючи політичну ситуацію в державі,
демографічні чинники,
традиції, культуру тощо.
Втім наш світ складається
з державних утворень.
І тому кожна держава і
кожен уряд на своїй території
завжди проводить певну політику –
це може бути або культурна політика,
або економічна політика і також
сюди належить і демографічна політика.
Демографічна політика – це цілеспрямована
діяльність державних органів
та інших соціальних
інституцій з метою збереження
або зміни тенденцій у
демографічних процесах.
І тепер пропоную дізнатися – якою
може бути демографічна політика?
Які цілі вона може переслідувати?
Для цього подивимося на схему, яка
відображає цілі демографічної політики.
Уявімо ситуацію, наприклад, Китаю,
де стрімкими темпами
зростає кількість населення,
вже недостатньо території
цієї держави і відповідно
саме така ситуація спричинила те,
що в 1984 році Китай почав
проводити демографічну політику
задля скорочення та
стабілізації чисельності населення.
Зокрема, для цього в Китаї були
прийняті певні законодавчі норми,
що обмежували кількість дітей в родині.
Наприклад, тим родинам, які
планували мати лише одну дитину –
надавалися квартири, соціальні
пільги тощо, в той час як тим сім’ям,
які все ж таки вирішували
народити другу чи третю дитину,
навпаки – приписувалися штрафи і,
навпаки, ускладнювалося їх життя.
Таку демографічну політику з
метою скорочення кількості населення
Китай проводив досить
довго – аж до 2015 року.
Припинення цієї демографічної політики
було спричинено швидким старінням
китайського населення і
також значним переважанням
чисельності чоловіків
над чисельністю жінок.
Це було свого часу викликано тим,
що коли родина в період обмеження
можливості народити більш ніж
одну дитину обирала кого вона хоче –
хлопчика чи дівчинку, то за
китайськими традиціями все ж таки
обирали хлопчика, бо в Китаї
хлопчик означає – син сонця.
Також ще однією ціллю
демографічної політики
може бути навпаки – збільшення населення.
Така ціль географічної політики зазвичай
переслідується розвиненими країнами
Європи та Північної
Америки, які характеризуються
швидкими темпами демографічного старіння.
Звичайно, вони зацікавлені в тому,
щоб у їх структурі населення
збільшувалася кількість дітей і молоді.
І до шляхів підвищування
народжуваності належить,
зокрема, можливість декретної відпустки
як для жінок, так і для чоловіків,
а також цьому сприяють
високий рівень медицини та
високий рівень економічної
стабільності країни.
Ну і також, звичайно, є країни, які не
ведуть жодної демографічної політики.
Так відбувається не тому, що в них
немає якихось проблем з цієї точки зору,
просто зазвичай – це країни, які поки що
не вирішили опікуватися цим питанням.
Сюди належать
переважно найбільш
бідні африканські країни,
що тільки-тільки розвиваються.
А тепер давайте дізнаємось – яким чином
держави проводять свою
демографічну політику?
За допомогою яких
заходів це можна здійснити?
Загалом виділяють три групи
заходів демографічної політики.
До першої групи належать законодавчі
або адміністративно-правові заходи.
Наприклад, це можуть бути законодавчі
акти, що регламентують шлюби,
охорона материнства і дитинства,
визначають мінімальний вік вступу до шлюбу
або також це можуть бути
різні пільги для батьків тощо.
Друга група заходів демографічної
політики – це економічні заходи.
Зокрема, це може бути
економічна допомога сім’ям,
гранти на освіту, субсидії
на житло, податкові
пільги сім’ям з великою кількість дітей
або особливі пільги одиноким батькам.
До третьої групи заходів
демографічної політики належать
соціально-психологічні заходи
або заходи ідеологічного впливу.
Наприклад, в суспільстві може
пропагуватися культ традиційної родини,
яка має багато дітей або, навпаки –
можуть бути поширені ідеї про
індивідуальний спосіб життя і childfree.
Кожна держава і кожне
суспільство вибирає для себе.
Таким чином, сьогодні на уроці
ми з вами дізналися багато нового
про динаміку чисельності
населення в світі,
про його кількість, надзвичайно
швидкі темпи зростання.
Вивчили: що означає
поняття “демографічний вибух”,
”демографічне старіння”
та ”демографічна криза”.
Навчилися читати статево-вікову піраміду.
Запам’ятали: що таке
демографічна політика,
які її цілі та які заходи
вона може використовувати.
А тепер давайте себе перевіримо.
Зараз я зачитаю питання, кожне
з яких містить декілька відповідей.
Скажу одразу, що в кожному
питанні правильна відповідь лише одна.
Їх я надам на початку наступного уроку.
Уважно слухаємо та відповідаємо.
Перше питання:
для якого макрорегіону світу найбільше
характерний демографічний вибух?
Варіант “А”: Океанія; варіант ”Б”: Європа;
варіант ”В”: Азія; варіант ”Г”: Америка.
Друге питання:
прикладом якого чиннику природного приросту
є бебі-бум після ІІ Світової війни?
Варіант “А”: соціально-економічного;
варіант ”Б”: психологічного;
варіант ”В”: політичного;
варіант ”Г”: військового.
І третє питання:
простий тип відтворення
населення призводить до …?
Варіант “А”: зростання
чисельності населення;
варіант ”Б”: чисельність
населення залишається сталою;
варіант ”В”: кількість
населення зменшується.
Будь ласка, подумайте та
дайте відповіді на ці питання.
А тепер переходимо до домашнього завдання.
Домашнє завдання на наступний урок.
По-друге, будь ласка, на контурній
карті позначте країни з найбільш швидкими
вивчити типи відтворення населення
та фази демографічного переходу.
По-друге,
будь ласка, на контурній карті
позначте країни з найбільш швидкими
темпами зростання населення
та поясніть, чому так відбувається.
І третє питання, дуже цікаве:
складіть перелік заходів демографічної
політики для однієї із країн світу.
Державу обираєте за власними почуттями.
Дякую за увагу і до зустрічі!